it's an exhibit that's 66 million years
in the making
today the Smithsonian National Museum of
Natural History opens its long-awaited
dinosaur exhibit it's the culmination of
five years worth of renovations that
cost a hundred and twenty-five million
dollars and as we hear from chip Reed
for that price you know that it features
the star of the prehistoric world meet
the nation's t-rex one of the most
complete t-rex --es in the world it's
almost entirely real fossils not plaster
and instead of standing like it's posing
for a selfie this one is jumping on an
unfortunate triceratops experts
painstakingly rebuilt the creatures
piece by piece using the latest
knowledge to make them look more real
Matthew Carano is the museum's curator
of dinosauria they look realer I think
when you portray them doing real things
so like eating another diamond yeah like
eating or sleeping or you know all the
different things animals do not just
posing for a picture I think even though
most of our dinosaurs were real last
time they just looked kind of dusty and
old and static if this is what you
envision when you think of a t-rex you
might not be that far off
when you watch Jurassic Park and you see
the Tyrannosaurus Rex real fake they did
a pretty good job they did it probably
isn't an animal that roared but movies
need things that are loud so that's fine
Carano knew he wanted to be a dinosaur
scientist when he was in the second
grade but his obsession goes way beyond
the main attraction a lot of kids have
an obsession or at least a fascination
with the Tyrannosaurus Rex do you I am
you know kind of over t-rex personally
it's you know it's our most famous movie
star it's a movie star doesn't need my
help and it's not just about dinosaurs
you'll also see creatures ranging from
the mastodon to the swalot corax a
prehistoric shark and fins
siobhan stars oversees the project and
its dozens of experts when you tell
people you've got to come to this
exhibit what do you tell them I tell
them that it's unique it's one-of-a-kind
they will never find another fossil haul
like and it's not just about dinosaurs
like the t-rex exactly for Matthew
Carano
his inner child has played a central
role when you're deciding how to portray
a dinosaur is that the ten-year-old in
you or the you of today who's deciding
what to do well it's the ten-year-old in
me getting permission from the scientist
to show something so because it's got to
be real it's got to be real what do you
want a 10 year old kid or an 80 year old
person to think and feel when they leave
this exhibit I want them to come in and
sort of have their minds blown just by
what's in front of them you think they
will be I'm sure they will be the t-rex
has to blow your mind that's pretty much
but I love that he says it probably
isn't an animal that roared sound I
wonder hmm we'll figure that one out